everything seemed to take so much longer
well it's because everything was new and
you were constantly learning so sort of
the takeaway there is that
learning and doing new things
um is kind of like a wake-up almost
right it's like you're forced into
presence and awareness because you don't
know how to do the thing and it can slow
down time your perception of time which
is pretty cool bro you [ __ ] nailed it
you absolutely nailed it i've been
thinking about this for so long i put a
tweet out the other day that said um
life doesn't go past any quicker as you
get older you're just paying less
attention and i got a load of replies
from people that were adamant that no
well it's because one year when you're
one year old means that that's 100 of
your life and one year when you're 50
years old is 150th of your life
okay that's true but you're not
absorbing your entirety of existence all
at the same time that's not how life
works the reason that your life appears
to move quicker is that you no longer
have a learner's mind you are simply
exactly paying less attention what
people mean when they say life seems to
be moving so fast where did the days go
is i don't remember where the days went
like people spend [ __ ] months on end
doing nothing memorable with their time
and then complain that they can't
remember it it's like bro you're making
your days forgettable you're not doing
anything that is worthy of your mind
remembering it you drive the same route
to work to and from work that's a
thousand journeys maybe that you've made
over the last couple of years they've
all been condensed down into one memory
think about the last time that you went
away on holiday the two here's the two
things the two things i've learned on my
research that you want if you want to
slow your life down a novelty and
intensity those are the two things that
you can manipulate most effectively
so think about the last time that you
went away on holiday and think about
not who you sat next to on the plane
because you've done plane journeys
before but if it was a new airport where
you arrived and the person that greeted
you with immigration and the taxi driver
that picked you up outside and the dude
i went to africa
five and a bit years ago and i remember
the book that the guy who met us at
reception
carried under his arm as we walked down
i remember the way that his shoes look i
remember the
the favorite bird that he had from the
local environment i remember his name
dennis it was like a given name he was
he was like rwandan he definitely wasn't
called dennis um
i remember all of that
why what i can't remember the 16 digit
number off the front of my [ __ ]
credit card that i've had for four years
why is it that i can remember dennis and
his shoes and his book and his favorite
bird novelty and intensity yeah that is
the way to slow down life so for the
people and this is you know it's a mem
reminder for me as well i i get pissed
that it's the same it's your routine
that's causing that to happen
vary the things that you do and
vary the route that you drive to work it
sounds so dumb but like vary the route
that you drive to work very way you sit
in the coffee shop that you go to every
day you know say something different to
someone go up and speak to somebody the
more that you do that the slower that
life is going to exist and really the
goal of life as far as i can see it
is to live a life that in retrospect
you're glad you lived
very much of our existence is actually
lived looking backward at the days that
we've had because the present moment is
fleeting the present moment exists now
and now and now and now and now it never
exists for a prolonged period of time
but memories last forever
so the way that you can see your
existence is basically that every single
moment that you live can be a gift to
the future version of you to look back
on with pleasure
yeah exactly and i think this phenomenon
also explains why you have people report
that time has seemed to go by super fast
during covid people are like oh god that
like we're in 2022 how did that happen
it feels like it's been a month well
it's because we've all been sitting in
our houses the last two years and like
haven't gone out as much haven't you
know gone to concerts haven't gone to a
restaurant like just haven't done any
new stuff i've been traveling haven't
done a lot of stuff what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you